bonjour casimir à bonjour julie tu
cherche quelque chose
casimir qu'est ce que tu as perdu
qu'est ce que c'est laissez-moi julie
caillerez alors alors rien par deloitte
avoir dérangé bonjour quasi mais tu as
perdu quelque chose à bonjour françois
un tu n'as pas vu le mois de mai nous
mener oui le mois de mai mais écoute
casimir le modeler se trouve entre entre
le mois d'avril et le mois de juin mais
mais c'est pas par terre que tu le
trouveras tu es sûre ni évidemment kg
mais bon merci art excuse-moi françois
mais je t'en prie de rien casimir que je
suis bête alors je ne suis pas plus
avancé maintenant le mois de mai est
entre le mois d'avril et le mois de juin
mais étant donné que je ne sais pas où
se trouvent les autres mois à l'orangé
au casino bonnet mais qu'est ce que ça
aille à monsieur li na bonjour je suis
content de vous voir
savez-vous quel mois nous sommes oui
nous sommes le mois de novembre pourquoi
novembre pour rien merci monsieur lui
sinon c'est tout ce que je peux faire
pourtant nombreuses et bien oui c'est
tout c'est tout ah bon très bien alors
je m'en vais j'ai eu un rendez vous très
important avec une contexte
oui tout le monde s'est tu restes j'ai
deviné
abo alors je m'en vais donc revoir
quasiment voir
il faudra quand même expliquer à un jour
qu'il n'y a pas de contact sur l'île aux
enfants alors casimir tu as trouvé ce
qu'ils cherchaient
or julie ça ne va pas j'ai un problème
qu'est ce qui t'arrive encore je ne sais
pas si le mois de novembre est à voir le
mois de mai c'est une question qui n'est
pas facile là non mais si tu veux nous
allons trouver françois tu sais qu'il
connaît tous il te trouvera sans doute
une explication au bas allons revoir
vivants france soir oui je les à tmoe
toi tu es encore un problème ben oui je
voudrais savoir si le mois de novembre
est avant le mois de mai et si le mois
de juin est après le mois de novembre
écoute casimir julie et moi nous allons
expliquer tout ça portera plutôt une
très jolie histoire tu veux bien mais
oui moi j'adore les histoires là mais
n'est donc pas vous donner les enfants
venaient tous vous êtes tous là et vous
aussi chez vous écoutez bien voici
l'histoire des mois il était une fois
une très gentille maman qui avait douze
garçons
cette dame s'appelait anne et ses
enfants s'appelait moi le premier enfant
l'aîné de la famille s'appelait janvier
sani s'en suit un événement est il son
anniversaire est le jour où les gens se
souhaite le plus de bonheur en se disant
bonne année le deuxième garçon n'a pas
beaucoup grandi c'était février vous
savez qu'il n'a que 28 ou 29 jours
vizille et reggae il adore se déguiser
en clown et faire des pitreries parce
que c'est l'époque du carnaval le
troisième garçon s'appelait mars
et le quatrième garçon s'appelait avril
ils se disputaient tout le temps pour
avoir les autres parcs et il faut bien
dire qu'on ne sait jamais très bien
chaque année celui qui les a pris le 5e
mais était le plus dynamique le plus
grand du sport
le sixième était le plus studieux il
travaillait tout le temps afin de passer
des examens et des concours pour passer
dans la classe au dessus
il s'appelait juin le 7e et le 8e et
garçons étaient jumeaux vous savez ils
ont tous les deux 31 jours ce sont les
mois de juillet et d'août
juillet était très musiciens il adorait
les balles que les feux d'artifice
tandis que le mois d'août était le plus
grand fini on ne travaille jamais et se
reposer toute la journée
le neuvième garçon était certainement le
plus courageux
il s'appelait septembre il aimait bien
l'odeur des cahiers neufs et ils se
faisaient toujours beaucoup de nouveaux
amis
les dix yen était le plus poète qu'il
aimait la couleur des arbres quand ils
jouissaient et les grandes promenades à
travers champs c'était octobre le 11e
l'avant dernier garçon était très triste
et très mélancolique il passait son
temps à regarder par la fenêtre
la pluie tombée sur les vitres il
s'appelait novembre il le dernier
du plus petit c'était décembre l'enfant
chéri de sa maman année c'est pourquoi
il est toujours plein de cadeaux de
friandises et bien voilà quasiment à
présent dû connaître tous les enfants de
la maman année ouais tu veux que
françois et les enfants te répètes leur
nom à henry s'il te plaît françois
allons-y alors il ironique janvier
février mars avril mai prove-it joueurs
juillet ou septembre octobre novembre et
décembre fait bien 12 juin mais françois
tu es formidable
comment fais tu pour tout savoir mais
c'est sain que le désigner j'étudie
savent
samour
un progrès
messi
mon rêve
j'aimerais
mais pour nous
[Musique]
ont des vues extraordinaires
je
qu'on m'explique scène
faire que voudrait être très savants
connaître le secret des chenillettes
irak ont quelque part des éléphants
reste aucun actif deviner ce qu'on
trouve au delà des épaules qui voit-on
parfois tellure des hommes d'essayage
les moineaux les corbeaux et les
blanches ou pleurer
des canadairs tous là
les connaît mais parce qu'ils sont de
vrais mammifères
bon sang
deux voies
curieux comme dell
la mère je voudrais être très sans
connaître les secrets des chemins qui y
at-il vraiment quelque part des
éléphants roses kakadu deviner ce putsch
au delà des étoiles qui voit-on par watt
ayons des hommes ou des cigales
[Musique]
c'est ce que je voudrais
à
ah ah
[Musique]